speaking of things i can't unsee i keep
seeing these videos of klaus schwab from
the world economic forum all over uh you
know mostly on twitter but all over the
online world you don't see them ever on
mainstream media and the world economic
forum is basically this group this
globalist group that is putting leaders
in all of our countries justin trudeau
was one of their young proteges here's a
video from klaus schwab at the world
economic forum
waves of lockdowns and
stresses
of finding work
or returning
to workplaces
have even amplified
the existential and often silent
mental health
crisis so what should you do
you are calling for the international
community
to safeguard vaccine equity
to respond to copy 19
and prevent future health crisis
nobody will be safe
if not everybody is vaccinated
sarah the reason i wanted to throw this
yeah
exactly that was a threat that's that
was exactly my point the reason i wanted
to throw to this video after the trudeau
thing is it seems to me that all these
people have left
and i mean this the democrats these
world economic all they have left is
that we need them because things are
horrible they're going to get worse and
they're also telling us they're the ones
that are going to make it worse in
essence i mean it's extraordinary isn't
it
it really is it's also extraordinary
that you know you get call i'm going to
be really careful with my words here
dave uh from just for for you for for
the sake of your youtube here um
it
i'll i'll state a fact here klaus schwab
wrote a book in 2020
it is called the great reset you can
look it up on amazon in which he laid
out
uh exactly
what it would look like if you used a
crisis like covet 19 which is what he
wrote about
these are all
facts
and you used that crisis that pandemic
to create a new
world no i'll say a new global alliance
and the only way that they know that
they can do that is by instilling fear
in people and at first i think they
found it to be a little bit easier than
it is now because you know people's
loved ones were in the hospital they
were sick we saw all of these videos
coming out from china at the beginning
of people literally dropping dead in the
streets and nobody knew why i mean there
was reason for some americans to be
alarmed and to be fearful now all they
have is this vaccine that by the way
won't prevent you from getting sick or
going to the hospital but they're still
going to threaten you that if you don't
get it you're going to be left behind it
is it's mind-boggling that they can't
give this up but as we know uh once you
get that power you're not going to
relinquish it you're just going to
continue to want more and more and more
it's just crazy to me that this is
happening right under everyone's noses
and i'm still called a conspiracy
theorist for saying they've literally
laid out that they were going to do this
and now it's happening
why is anyone shocked i know that's
almost part of it that it all happens
those of us that are paying attention
see it and in some ways that makes other
people think we're even crazy or
something like that uh ezra i should
mention that your
we put on your lower third
journalist without air quotes because
it's so refreshing for me to be able to
call someone an actual journalist that
is your special lower third for today uh
nick uh did you see this video earlier
this week where the biden administration
official who of course is a former
blackrock guy was saying that if in
essence we don't go to war with ukraine
and save the liberal world order then
everything's going to collapse that's
sort of directly connected to this isn't
it this idea that we have to you know go
to these wars that we don't declare and
we have to pay more at the pump and
everything else to save the liberal
world order wouldn't that have been like
an alex jones thing a couple years back
right they're saying the quiet parts out
loud now and what you're seeing is that
with even with the covet stuff that's
still going on in in la county they're
bringing back masks for indoors uh
they're never you never are boosted
enough you know
the screen actors guild union has uh
reinstituted masks on set at all time
whether
and you have to be vaccinated and
boosted in order to work and what i
think is that all of these people in
these uh positions that have been put
there like gavin newsom like uh
like trudeau they are not they their
allegiance is not to their constituency
their allegiance is not to their voters
their allegiance is to this global
liberal order that they all want to
participate in and they want to bring
every nation
under the sway of and uh i know that
sounds like a big sweeping pronouncement
but that's what i think is going on uh
gavin newsom really isn't in danger
from his voters because
they've changed the electoral system in
california so that he really can't be
removed by the voters and that's why so
many people like you and i dave have
gotten the heck out of california and
got gone to some place where you at
least your vote means something your
vote doesn't mean anything in california
because the vote the politicians in
california like newsome don't have to be
scared of what you think of what they do
don't worry nick i'm not going to tell
people where you're under underground
bunker that you're reporting from right
now is that's right i'm the insurrection
guy i'm waiting for the fbi to come
after me it's like
why haven't they come and get me yet it
would make a great ending to the movie
oh it would make a great ending to this
youtube show too i mean that would be
the perfect moment oh my i hear
something